This is my 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The Tokyo Rail and Metro Systems make up one of the largest rapid transit networks in the world. More than 14 billion people walk through its turnstiles every year. That's about 40 million rides every single day. On a typical morning during rush hour, commuters stand cheek to jaw in crammed train carriages.
这是我的《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。东京的铁路和地铁系统构成了世界上规模最大的快速交通网络之一。每年有超过140亿人次穿过它的检票闸机。这意味着每天大约有4000万人次乘坐。在典型的早高峰期间，通勤者在拥挤的车厢里脸贴着脸，挤得水泄不通。
The busiest stations even employ people busher's known as Oshia, who make sure everyone is packed in before the doors close. But last year, at the start of the COVID epidemic, after the Japanese government declared a state of emergency, the trains emptied out. That's Tokyo-based producer Daniel Simo. Suddenly, there were no O ashia to be seen. In fact, the trains were so empty in the mornings that if you had to take one, there was no need to stand anymore.
最繁忙的车站甚至雇佣了被称为“推手”（Oshia）的工作人员，他们确保在车门关闭前把每个人都塞进去。但去年，在新冠疫情爆发之初，日本政府宣布进入紧急状态后，列车变得空空荡荡。那是驻东京的制片人丹尼尔·西莫。突然间，再也看不到“推手”了。事实上，早晨的列车空到如果你必须乘坐，根本不需要站着。
For a few weeks at least, most people had stopped riding the train. Most, but not all. It was kind of strange because everybody was supposed to stay at home, but I had to go out every single day. That's Mio Tanaka. She's not a health professional or an essential worker. She runs a company in Tokyo that helps foreign businesses set up in Japan. And yet, at the height of the pandemic, she's still found herself commuting on a daily basis and not just in the metro and not just to one place. So during the COVID my day looked like visiting office in the morning, then take a train,
至少有几周时间，大多数人都停止了乘坐火车。大多数人，但不是全部。这有点奇怪，因为每个人都被要求待在家里，但我每天都必须出门。那是田中美穗。她不是医疗专业人员，也不是必要岗位工作人员。她在东京经营一家帮助外国企业在日本落户的公司。然而，在疫情最严重的时候，她发现自己仍然每天都在通勤，而且不仅仅是乘坐地铁，也不仅仅是去一个地方。所以疫情期间，我的一天就是早上拜访办公室，然后坐火车，
then taking a bus, then go to another office. So I was a bit scared at that time. But despite the obvious danger, Miho Tanaka had no choice. She was beholden to an old Japanese custom. It's just because every single time I had to stamp some documents with Hanko. Hanko, or in show, as they are sometimes called, are the carved stamp seals that people in Japan often use in place of signatures. Hanko seals are made from materials ranging from plastic to jade and are about the size of a tube of lipstick. The end of each hankou is etched with its own name, usually in the kanji pictorial characters used in Japanese writing.
然后坐公交车，再去另一间办公室。所以我当时有点害怕。但尽管有明显的危险，田中美穗别无选择。她受制于一种古老的日本习俗。这只是因为每次我都必须用印章（Hanko）在一些文件上盖章。印章，或者有时被称为“印鉴”（Insho），是日本人们经常用来代替签名的雕刻印章。印章的材质从塑料到玉石不等，大小约为一支唇膏。每个印章的末端都刻有名字，通常是日语书写中使用的汉字。
This carved end is then dipped in red cinnabat paste and impressed on a document as a form of identification. Hongou seules work like signatures, only instead of signing on a dotted line, you impress your hunko on a small circle to prove your identity. But unlike a signature, which you can make with any old pen or touch screen, in Japan, you need to have your own personal hanko with you whenever you stamp something, and you have to stamp it in person. And there is a lot that needs stamping. Just ask me how.
这个雕刻的末端会蘸上红色的朱砂印泥，并印在文件上作为一种身份证明。印章的作用就像签名，只是你不是在虚线上签名，而是把印章盖在一个小圆圈里来证明你的身份。但与可以用任何旧笔或触摸屏完成的签名不同，在日本，无论你盖什么章，都需要随身携带自己的个人印章，而且必须亲自盖章。而且有很多东西需要盖章。问问美穗就知道了。
For example, on Monday I visit tax office on Tuesday I visit bank on Wednesday I visit legal affairs bureau and I brought a bank all every single time to stamp some different documents for different procedures. To sign for a package, You need a Hanco. To clock in and out of work. You need a Hanco. To finalize business contracts. You need a Hanco.
例如，周一我拜访税务局，周二我拜访银行，周三我拜访法务局，我每次都带着印章去为不同的程序盖不同的文件。要签收包裹，你需要印章。上下班打卡，你需要印章。敲定商业合同，你需要印章。
And there's not just one kind of Hanco. No, that would be too easy. You might have one cheap Hanco you carry in your bag every day. And another fancy one stored in a safe deposit box that you might only use once or twice in your life. Mijo's job involves a lot of paperwork at government offices, so she often has to use different Hanco for herself and her clients. I have my personal Hanco Plus company Hanco, and when I have to do some procedures in a bank, then I have to bring a hanko for a bank. And did you ever get confused or you take the wrong one, for example?
而且印章不止一种。不，那太简单了。你可能有一个每天放在包里的廉价印章，还有一个存放在保险箱里、一生可能只用一两次的高级印章。美穗的工作涉及大量政府办公室的文书工作，所以她经常不得不为自己和客户使用不同的印章。我有我的个人印章加上公司印章，当我在银行办理一些手续时，我就必须带上银行用的印章。你有没有弄混过，或者拿错了，比如？
Always. Yeah, always. And Mijo is not the only one stuck endlessly running around with their hanko. Last March, in the midst of the pandemic, even as everyone was being encouraged to work from home, many people in Japan still needed to do a lot of paperwork. For some, that meant getting on train and traveling halfway across the city, just to stamp a single document. Like a lot of people, I often find Hanco beautiful. Not just the kanji characters or the physical seals themselves. There's also just something
总是弄混。是的，总是。而且美穗并不是唯一一个被无休止地带着印章四处奔波所困扰的人。去年三月，在疫情期间，即使每个人都被鼓励在家工作，日本的许多人仍然需要处理大量的文书工作。对一些人来说，这意味着要坐火车穿越半个城市，只为了盖一个文件。像许多人一样，我经常觉得印章很美。不仅仅是汉字或印章本身。还有一些
undeniably cool about the act of impressing a hanko onto a document. It's one of the small traditions that makes Japan, Japan. But even most Japanese have gotten to the point where they're fed up with the whole hanko system. So how did Japan get here then? Two decades into the 21st century, why do the Japanese still need to use this ancient analog thing? Because Honkou didn't used to be everywhere in Japan. In fact, they weren't even originally Japanese. The earliest feel that is known to have
不可否认的酷，那就是将印章盖在文件上的动作。这是让日本成为日本的小传统之一。但即使是大多数日本人也已经到了对整个印章系统感到厌倦的地步。那么日本是怎么走到这一步的呢？进入21世纪二十年了，为什么日本人仍然需要使用这种古老的模拟事物？因为印章过去并不是在日本随处可见的。事实上，它们最初甚至不是日本的。已知最早的印章
gone from China to Japan dates to I think the year 57 AD and that apparently was given by the Chinese emperor. That's Philip Hoo, curator of Asian art at the St. Louis Art Museum and an expert in East Asian Seals. And interestingly, it was a golden seal. It was a seal made of solid gold. Who says the earliest Hancock was status symbols used by the likes of emperors, court officials and samurai? They were made of materials like soapstone and jade, and were engraved using seal script, a form of caligraphic writing. But they were not the kind of thing you saw every day. Theals were very much part of the imperial and civil bureaucracy of Japan.
从中国传到日本的时间大概是公元57年，显然那是中国皇帝赐予的。那是圣路易斯艺术博物馆亚洲艺术策展人、东亚印章专家菲利普·胡。有趣的是，那是一枚金印。那是一枚纯金打造的印章。胡说，最早的印章是皇帝、朝廷官员和武士等使用的身份象征。它们由滑石和玉石等材料制成，并使用篆书（一种书法字体）雕刻。但它们不是你每天都能看到的东西。这些印章在很大程度上是日本帝国和文官官僚体系的一部分。
But at that time, not popular amongst ordinary people. That's because for much of Japan's history, most ordinary people only had given names, or what in the West might be called first names. If you did have a surname, it was usually shit with your entire community. Only members of the feudal aristocracy had the kind of specific family names that you might put on a Hanco. And starting in the 1600s, Japan's Shogun rulers imposed a policy of strict international isolation, cutting Japan off from the rest of the world and effectively preserving this feudal system. So even as late as the 19th century,
但在当时，在普通民众中并不流行。这是因为在日本历史的大部分时间里，大多数普通人只有名字，或者西方所说的“名”。如果你有姓氏，它通常与你整个社区共享。只有封建贵族阶层才有那种你可能会刻在印章上的特定家族姓氏。从1600年代开始，日本的幕府统治者实施了严格的国际孤立政策，将日本与世界其他地区隔绝，并有效地保留了这种封建制度。所以即使到了19世纪，
most people in Japan didn't really use seals or need them. But things would soon change. Things in part to Matthew Perry. No, not that Matthew Perry. So in 1853, Commodore Matthew Perry, who shares the same name with the friends actor, he shows up with four modern US naval warships and basically forces Japan to open back up.
日本的大多数人并没有真正使用印章或需要它们。但事情很快就会改变。这在一定程度上要归功于马修·佩里。不，不是那个《老友记》里的马修·佩里。1853年，与那位《老友记》演员同名的马修·佩里准将，带着四艘现代化的美国海军军舰出现，基本上强迫日本重新开放。
Nika Poe is a professor of Japanese history at Rutgers University. And this has a huge impact. It's kind of difficult to overstate just how much society changed. The arrival of Paris fleet kicked off a period known as the May-G restoration, in which Japan transformed itself into a modern industrialized nation state. The old feudal system of the Shogunet was done away with, and replaced with a centralized state bureaucracy, which proceeded to change almost everything about how society was structured. They passed a land reform. They instituted free public schooling.
尼卡·波是罗格斯大学的日本历史教授。这产生了巨大的影响。很难夸大社会变化的程度。佩里舰队的到来开启了被称为“明治维新”的时期，日本在此期间将自己转型为一个现代工业化的民族国家。旧的幕府封建制度被废除，取而代之的是中央集权的官僚机构，它着手改变社会结构的几乎所有方面。他们进行了土地改革。他们建立了免费公共教育。
They instituted mandatory conscription. They created a modern military. But in order to do any of that effectively, the new bureaucratic regime needed to make one additional change. Everyone in Japan would have to choose surnames. In the old feudal system, there hadn't been any need for most people to possess distinct names, but the Japanese state now wanted to keep much closer track of who was who.
他们实行了义务征兵制。他们建立了一支现代军队。但为了有效地做到这一切，新的官僚政权需要做出一个额外的改变。日本的每个人都必须选择姓氏。在旧的封建制度下，大多数人不需要拥有独特的姓氏，但日本政府现在希望更密切地追踪谁是谁。
So in 1875, a law was passed requiring every citizen to register a family name. Those who were too slow in claiming a surname could even be penalized, and in the mad dash that followed, some people just made names up, usually by smashing together words and syllables that had never been combined before. So, as a result of this, you know, sometimes even illiterate farmers just came up with crazy surnames. Even today in Japan, you can find families with names like Cat House, Cow Poop, or simply the number 735.
因此在1875年，一项法律通过，要求每个公民登记一个姓氏。那些在认领姓氏方面太慢的人甚至可能受到惩罚，在随后的疯狂抢注中，有些人只是编造了名字，通常是将以前从未组合过的词汇和音节拼凑在一起。所以，结果就是，你知道，有时甚至是文盲农民也想出了疯狂的姓氏。即使在今天的日本，你也能找到姓氏为“猫屋”、“牛粪”或仅仅是数字“735”的家庭。
Lou, my personal favorite surname has to be God. That's it, just God. I'm Joe God. So Japan has maybe the largest variety of surnames of any country per capita. But it wasn't enough that everyone have their own unique-ish name. In this new modern Japan, everyone now also needed their own, Hanko.
卢，我个人最喜欢的姓氏一定是“神”。就是这样，只是“神”。我是乔·神。所以日本的人均姓氏种类可能是世界上最多的。但每个人都有自己独特的姓氏还不够。在这个现代化的新日本，每个人现在还需要自己的印章。
So the introduction of seals for everyday use by ordinary citizens was by design. It didn't happen organically. It was more or less by decree. Suddenly, Hanko went from rarefied status symbols to something that almost everyone had, because they had to, and soon, seal manufacturing became its own major industry. You would actually employ a seal-carver. These were specialized vendors, and all they did pretty much was calf seals for other people. Some carvers had large workshops.
因此，引入供普通公民日常使用的印章是刻意为之的。它不是自然发生的。它或多或少是法令规定的。突然间，印章从稀有的身份象征变成了几乎每个人都有的东西，因为他们必须有，很快，印章制造业就成了自己的一个主要产业。你实际上会雇佣一个刻章匠。这些是专门的商贩，他们几乎只为别人刻印章。有些刻章匠有大型作坊。
Others were a tinder and street vendors who made their way from town to town. And you know, whenever the carver came by your village or your town, and you needed a seal, you would immediately employ them before they moved on to another place. Eventually, there came to be three different types of honko, depending on the context. The regular everyday honko was called a metomian, and everybody has one, okay, and sort of little bag or whatever they carry around because it's so often required for you to just indicate that a transaction has taken place. There was also another type of personal seal used for banking called a ginko in.
另一些则是走街串巷的流动商贩。你知道，每当刻章匠来到你的村庄或城镇，而你需要一枚印章时，你会在他们前往下一个地方之前立即雇佣他们。最终，根据语境，出现了三种不同类型的印章。普通的日常印章被称为“认印”（Mitome-in），每个人都有一个，放在小包里或随身携带，因为经常需要它来表明交易已经发生。还有另一种用于银行的个人印章，称为“银行印”（Ginko-in）。
You might need one of these to make a deposit or transfer at your local branch. And then there was the jitsu in, which in English means a person's actual seal or their real seal. And a jitsu in is basically a proxy for the person. Jitsu in were not used very frequently, but instead reserved for the most important kinds of documents in a person's life, like mortgages and marriage certificates. It's kind of like having a social security number.
你可能需要用它在当地分行进行存款或转账。然后是“实印”（Jitsu-in），在英语中意为个人的实际印章或真实印章。实印基本上是本人的代理。实印使用频率不高，而是保留用于个人生活中最重要的文件，如抵押贷款和结婚证书。这有点像拥有一个社会保障号码。
If your social security number could only be written down in one place and had immense sentiment of value. Even today, families will have fancy jitsu and made for their children when they come of age and then store them in a deposit box for safe keeping. Because it's basically saying that I am the person buying a house or I am the person that's marrying you. And so it's very, very personal. In time, almost every element of government, business, and social life were systematized and put onto paper. Usually stand with one of these three Hanco.
如果你的社会保障号码只能写在一个地方，并且具有巨大的情感价值。即使在今天，家庭也会在孩子成年时为他们制作精美的实印，然后将其存放在保险箱中妥善保管。因为它基本上是在说，我就是那个买房子的人，或者我就是那个要和你结婚的人。所以它非常、非常个人化。久而久之，政府、商业和社会生活的几乎每个要素都被系统化并落实到纸面上。通常盖上这三种印章之一。
But Hanco would come to play an even more visible role in Japanese life in the 20th century. Thanks to a business practice called Nemawashi. Nemawashi is a very important consensus building procedure. Takau Kawasaki is a retired consultant who worked for 40 years for a large Japanese glass manufacturer and he says that building consensus through Nemawashi means laying the groundwork for any big decision by lobbying and consulting with everyone involved prior to moving forward. That means if you have an idea, you have to first approach all those concerned one by one, discuss your plan and get buy-in from each of them individually.
但印章在20世纪的日本生活中发挥了更显著的作用。这要归功于一种名为“合意”（Nemawashi）的商业惯例。高川川崎是一位退休顾问，曾在一家大型日本玻璃制造商工作了40年，他说通过“合意”建立共识意味着在推进任何重大决策之前，通过游说和咨询所有相关人员来打好基础。这意味着如果你有一个想法，你必须首先逐一接触所有相关人员，讨论你的计划并分别获得他们的认可。
This is done before any larger meeting. So I have to repeat five, six, or even seven times repeat the same explanation to every person to get it okay. And this is where Hancock comes in. Because as you move through the company from the lowest ranks to the highest, once someone understands and agrees with your idea, they get out their seal. Then everybody pressed the Hancock and so whole bunch of Hancock's around each company document. That document full of Hanco stamps is called a ringy.
这在任何大型会议之前完成。所以我必须重复五次、六次甚至七次同样的解释给每个人听，以获得同意。这就是印章发挥作用的地方。因为当你从公司最低层级升到最高层级时，一旦有人理解并同意你的想法，他们就会拿出他们的印章。然后每个人都盖上印章，所以每个公司文件周围都有一堆印章。那份盖满印章的文件被称为“禀议书”（Ringy）。
And if you look at all the stamps around the ringy, there's a sort of implicit code you can decipher, which tells you about things like a company's hierarchy. Bottom is a lower rank. Top is the higher rank. And if you reach the department head that levels, your Hancock getting a little bigger. So when you see the size of the Hancock, you can make a fair guess is what sort of a level that person is in
如果你看看禀议书周围所有的印章，有一种隐含的代码可以解读，它告诉你关于公司等级制度之类的事情。底部是较低的级别。顶部是较高的级别。如果你达到了部门主管级别，你的印章会变大一点。所以当你看到印章的大小时，你可以合理猜测那个人的级别。
organization. And naturally, the CEO's Hancock is the biggest. Although if you really want to go big, be sure to Google the Emperor Seal. It's roughly the size of a pro wrestler's fist. It uses a special ink. It's made of solid gold. And it weighs 10 pounds. Even the exact angle of a stamp on a document can reveal something about the person's place in the power structure. A CEO's seal, for example, might be a fixed perfectly straight up and down, with the top of the seal at 12 o'clock, while the top lieutenant seals would be slightly rotated.
组织中。自然，CEO的印章是最大的。虽然如果你真的想看大的，一定要去谷歌搜索“天皇御玺”。它大约有一个职业摔跤手的拳头那么大。它使用特殊的墨水。它由纯金制成。重达10磅。即使是文件上印章的确切角度也能揭示关于此人在权力结构中位置的信息。例如，CEO的印章可能盖得非常正，印章顶部指向12点钟方向，而高级副手的印章会稍微旋转。
Middle management would be angled just a bit further, and so on down the line, with each seal paying deference to those above it. Funny thing though, occasionally one st-on person may now completely agree. In which case, they might still sign off on the plan, but in order to signal that they weren't really totally on board, deliberately they'd angle their stamp just a little too far. And he praised the Hancock 45 degrees turn. Once finished, this Hancock's stre document is a sign that everyone had been consulted and brought in on the latest plan.
中层管理的印章角度会再偏一点，以此类推，每个印章都向上面的人表示敬意。不过有趣的是，偶尔有一个人可能并不完全同意。在这种情况下，他们可能仍然会在计划上签字，但为了表明他们并不是完全赞同，他们会故意把印章的角度转得太偏。他称之为印章45度转弯。一旦完成，这份盖满印章的文件就标志着每个人都经过了咨询，并被纳入了最新的计划中。
So take style, head of a lot, yes. But by the time the final decision is made, everybody is in the same wave ranks, same direction, same goal, so the bull go without a hesitate. For a long time, Nemoashi was simply how business worked in Japan. There was a culture of consensus in which everyone at a company took on risks and rewards together, and it was often credited with Japan's incredible economic growth in the mid-20th century. And as Nemoashi's most visible symbol, the use of the honko went unquestioned. But that would start to change in the 1990s. Well, these GDP figures are very bad, much worse than was expected, and in fact one analyst here in Tokyo today called them worse than disastrous.
所以，是的，这很费时间。但当最终决定做出时，每个人都在同一条船上，方向一致，目标一致，所以事情会毫不犹豫地推进。很长一段时间以来，“合意”就是日本商业运作的方式。有一种共识文化，公司里的每个人共同承担风险和回报，这通常被认为是日本20世纪中期经济惊人增长的原因。作为“合意”最明显的象征，印章的使用从未受到质疑。但这在20世纪90年代开始改变。嗯，这些GDP数据非常糟糕，比预期的要差得多，事实上，东京的一位分析师今天称它们比灾难还要糟糕。
In the entire period, 1998 to 2003 was basically a period of recession and depression. It really hit Japan hard. Ulrika Sheda is a professor of Japanese business at the University of California, San Diego. And she says that Japan's recession in the 90s and early 2000s was so bad that the period would come to be referred to as the country's lost decade. And if you look at even at societal measures like robberies and break ins or other signs of social distress like divorce rates, everything went up. So those were really dark days.
整个1998年到2003年期间基本上是衰退和萧条时期。它确实重创了日本。乌尔丽卡·谢达是加州大学圣地亚哥分校的日本商业教授。她说，日本在90年代和21世纪初的衰退非常严重，以至于这一时期被称为该国的“失落的十年”。如果你看看抢劫和入室盗窃等社会指标，或者离婚率等其他社会困境迹象，一切都在上升。所以那些确实是黑暗的日子。
And that widespread anxiety had profound effect on the practice of Nema Washi and the Hanco system because it had been easy enough to stamp your approval on a business plan during the boom years when most plans worked. Deepa might have said, yeah, sure, that's fine. You know, even skip some steps, that's not sure. If we can produce it, we can sell it. Let's go, go, go. But once the economy spiraled,
这种广泛的焦虑对“合意”实践和印章系统产生了深远的影响，因为在经济繁荣时期，当大多数计划都奏效时，在商业计划上盖章表示批准是很容易的。人们可能说，是的，当然，没问题。你知道，甚至跳过一些步骤，那没关系。如果我们能生产它，我们就能卖掉它。冲冲冲。但一旦经济陷入螺旋式下降，
and the risks of stamping your hand go on something multiplied, suddenly everything becomes much more complicated because people say, no, I don't want to sign this or I need to get hand holding before I agree to this or I need something in return for agreeing to this. So the metabolism of the companies slowed down. And this is the word that the Japanese use to describe this. They actually think that the metabolism of the entire economy slowed down. And if that wasn't bad enough, this all happened at the same time that the internet was taking
在某事上盖章的风险成倍增加，突然间一切都变得复杂得多，因为人们说，不，我不想签这个，或者我需要先获得批准才能同意这个，或者我需要一些回报才同意这个。所以公司的代谢变慢了。这就是日本人用来描述这种情况的词。他们实际上认为整个经济的代谢变慢了。如果这还不够糟糕，这一切都发生在互联网正在兴起的同时。
off. And a tradition requiring people to stamp paper documents using special seals to be physically carried on their person at all times. Well, it hasn't exactly proved internet friendly. If anything, the Hunko has shackled Japan to the old paper system. It really is quite amazing how much paper documents rule the day in Japan. And because of the Hunko. Nick Capors says that the need to physically stamp things
而一个要求人们使用特殊印章在纸质文件上盖章，并且必须时刻随身携带的传统。嗯，它并没有证明对互联网友好。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是印章将日本束缚在了旧的纸质系统上。纸质文件在日本统治一切，这确实令人惊叹。而且因为印章的存在。尼克·卡波斯说，物理盖章的需求
disincentivizes people from ever digitizing documents. Since it's only a matter of time until you have to print any given document back out just so it can be stamped. And everything shuts down until somebody can get into the office and get this handcard of a drawer. Work orders, expense reports, any kind of official company communication, they all need to be in hard copy and certified with a stamp in person. When you go to the bank, when you go to any official, something even receiving the package from personal service, they use your preferred, the handker as a receipt.
阻碍了人们将文件数字化。因为迟早你必须把任何给定的文件打印出来，以便盖章。而且一切都会停摆，直到有人能进入办公室从抽屉里拿出这个印章。工作订单、费用报告、任何形式的官方公司通讯，都需要纸质副本并亲自盖章认证。当你去银行，当你去任何官方机构，甚至从个人服务处接收包裹时，他们都使用你首选的印章作为收据。
And the facts machine, I mean, people have commented on this a lot, but paper faxes are still the only way to get things done because everything requires paper documents that you can stamp on. Miho Tanaka remembers experiencing this kind of friction first hand at her last job, waiting around the office for her boss to stamp a document that could just as easily be signed online nearly anywhere else. Also, I cannot usually ask the other people to put the handkerchief on behalf of somebody else and usually on one paper, like five people have to put stamp. So yeah, that's very time consuming for everybody. When things like PDFs and digital signatures first appeared in the 1990s, many people in
还有传真机，我的意思是，人们对此评论很多，但纸质传真仍然是完成事情的唯一方式，因为一切都需要可以盖章的纸质文件。田中美穗记得在上一份工作中亲身经历过这种摩擦，在办公室里等着老板给一份文件盖章，而这份文件在其他任何地方都可以很容易地在线签署。而且，我通常不能要求其他人代表某人盖章，通常在一张纸上，五个人必须盖章。所以是的，这对每个人来说都非常耗时。当PDF和数字签名在20世纪90年代首次出现时，日本的许多人
Japan expected that a digital transformation was appeared in the 1990s, many people in Japan expected that a digital transformation was just around the corner, but it never really happened. And ironically, that is in part because of the slowness of Nemoashi and the Hancock system. Like literally the rules are so strict that there's just no way around that unless you change all these rules and that requires all these meetings and discussion and then people have to sign off on it, probably with a Hanco. But lately, it seems as if the cultural tide may have finally turned. Some large Japanese corporations have been quietly retiring the Hanco in recent years,
预计数字化转型即将来临，但它从未真正发生。讽刺的是，这在一定程度上是因为“合意”和印章系统的缓慢。字面上说，规则太严格了，除非你改变所有这些规则，否则没有办法绕过它，而这需要所有这些会议和讨论，然后人们必须签字，通常是用印章。但最近，文化潮流似乎终于转变了。一些大型日本企业近年来一直在悄悄淘汰印章，
and a younger generation of Japanese people like Mijo, who have no memory of the pre-intinate boom years, are using Hanko less and clicking boxes more. For example, my parents age like 50-60. They think Hanko is so important, but I think young generation wants to change ASAP, because we all get used to smart-fall in signature process, just like the other Western countries. And now the same state bureaucracy that created the modern Hancock system might have no choice but to kill it. Japan has declared a nationwide emergency as COVID-19 infections exceed 9,000. Medical experts have urged the government to take drastic countermeasures as quickly as possible to slow the contagion. Residents are being told to stay home to help stem the outbreak.
像美穗这样没有经历过前互联网繁荣年代的年轻一代日本人，正在减少使用印章，更多地点击复选框。例如，我父母那一代，50-60岁的人。他们认为印章非常重要，但我认为年轻一代想尽快改变，因为我们都习惯了像其他西方国家那样的智能手机签名流程。现在，创造了现代印章系统的同一个官僚机构可能别无选择，只能终结它。日本已宣布全国进入紧急状态，新冠感染人数超过9000人。医学专家敦促政府尽快采取严厉的应对措施以减缓传染。居民被告知待在家里以帮助遏制疫情。
There's increasing pressure to take stronger measures, including a total lockdown of the capital. When COVID first hit, there was a sense that Japan would be spared the worst of it and could keep doing businesses normal. But that didn't last long. Instead, the COVID pandemic finally did what years of bureaucratic stagnation could not. Stories like Miho's of Hancock procedures forcing people to brave train cars in the middle of a lockdown have finally spurred the government to act. In May 2021, the administration of Prime Minister Yoshihida Sugah enacted a set of laws establishing a new agency to speed up the process of digitization.
采取更强有力措施的压力越来越大，包括对首都进行全面封锁。当新冠疫情首次爆发时，人们有一种感觉，日本会幸免于难，可以继续照常营业。但这并没有持续多久。相反，新冠疫情最终做到了多年官僚停滞所做不到的事情。像美穗那样因印章程序迫使人们在封锁期间冒着风险乘坐火车的报道，终于促使政府采取了行动。2021年5月，菅义伟首相的政府颁布了一系列法律，成立了一个新机构以加快数字化进程。
This involved getting rid of Hancock for almost all government procedures. Many believe this government move is a watershed moment, including Oryka Sheda. Once it has no longer legal standing, I don't see how it can remain important in day-to-day life. It's a little bit sad, actually. But if there is no purpose to it, then people will happily let go. Well, of course, it's a tradition. But tradition can be killed. Takau Kawasaki is a creature of the Hanco happy boom years, if there ever was one.
这涉及在几乎所有政府程序中废除印章。许多人认为政府的这一举措是一个分水岭时刻，包括乌尔丽卡·谢达。一旦它不再具有法律地位，我不明白它如何在日常生活中保持重要性。实际上，这有点令人难过。但如果没有目的，那么人们会很高兴地放手。嗯，当然，这是一种传统。但传统是可以被终结的。高川川崎是印章繁荣年代的产物，如果曾经有过的话。
But he also no longer really sees the benefit of the seal system. To me, I'm rather an old man but the radical old man, I don't care. Because, uh, Megan Business, European Business, you know, have done the business for many, many years without a uncle. Why can't we? Just, just matter of change, just matter of accept. Still, there have been some who want to hold on to the old ways.
但他也不再真正看到印章系统的好处。对我来说，我是一个老头，但激进的老头，我不在乎。因为，呃，美国商业、欧洲商业，你知道，在没有印章的情况下做了很多很多年的生意。我们为什么不能？只是改变的问题，只是接受的问题。尽管如此，仍有一些人想要坚持旧的方式。
They worry that in end to Hanco also marks an end to the country's culture of consensus and shared responsibility in favor of a more western model based on individual accomplishment. One prefectural assembly has officially opposed the government move to phase out Hanco. Another group of lawmakers in the National Parliament recently formed a coalition to preserve them, kind of like a seal appreciation caucus. And in fact, a lot of people I spoke with, even if they recognize the practical need to phase it out for most situations, hope the Hanco won't disappear completely. Philip who concedes that maybe there
他们担心印章的终结也标志着该国共识和共同责任文化的终结，转而采用基于个人成就的西方模式。一个县议会已正式反对政府逐步淘汰印章的举措。国会中的另一群议员最近组成了一个联盟来保护它们，有点像“印章欣赏核心小组”。事实上，我交谈过的许多人，即使他们认识到在大多数情况下逐步淘汰它的实际需要，也希望印章不会完全消失。菲利普·胡承认，也许
shouldn't be three types of Hanco anymore, but can't we at least keep one? He points to the Jitsu in in particular, the real seal, the one that's only pulled out for the really big stuff. I mean, I think it's nice. I think the Jitsu is not such a bad idea to have some kind of personal ceremony to mark a decision of considerable importance in your life. Even Takau Kawasaki has a soft spot for the real seal. He says he fondly remembers using Ed Jitsun when he bought his first home. My father made my Jitsun when I got married and gave it to me. I still use it. And then my son was married
不应该再有三种类型的印章了，但我们至少能保留一种吗？他特别指出了“实印”，即真正的印章，那种只在处理非常重要的事情时才拿出来的印章。我的意思是，我认为这很好。我认为实印并不是一个坏主意，拥有某种个人仪式来标记你生活中相当重要的决定。即使是高川川崎对真正的印章也有偏爱。他说他深情地记得在他买第一套房子时使用他的实印。我结婚时，父亲为我制作了实印并给了我。我还在用它。然后我儿子结婚时
same way I made it and gave it to Shinjuku in Western Tokyo, there's a small Buddhist temple dedicated to Bishamontan, one of the seven lucky gods of Japanese folklore. This past October, a priest knelt by the temple's altar, rang a ball bell and chanted a sutra behind a plastic face shield. He was performing a memorial service for a batch of about 50 Hanco, brought to the temple by a group of nearby office workers. It's not uncommon for inanimate objects to receive funeral rights in Japan. They're a way to bid farewell and commemorate items that have served their purpose and are
同样的方式，我制作了它并给了他。在东京西部的新宿，有一座小型佛教寺庙，供奉着日本民间传说中的七福神之一——毗沙门天。去年十月，一位牧师跪在寺庙的祭坛旁，敲响了一个铃铛，并在塑料面罩后诵读经文。他正在为一批约50枚印章举行追悼会，这些印章是由附近的一群上班族带到寺庙的。在日本，无生命物体接受葬礼并不罕见。这是一种告别和纪念那些已经完成了使命的物品的方式，它们
no longer needed, like scissors, sewing needles, and honko. In fact, October 1st is Seal Day, when honko shops throughout the country hold memorial services for old retired seals. But at the temple in Shinjuku, there was a distinct sense that this funeral was different. There was a distinct sense that this funeral was different. At this time, it wasn't only these individual Hanco, to which Japan was saying goodbye. A Goregian. That story was produced by Daniel Simo and edited by Joe Rosenberg. When we come back, we'll talk to Daniel about a more problematic tradition involving
不再需要了，比如剪刀、缝纫针和印章。事实上，10月1日是“印章日”，全国各地的印章店都会为退休的旧印章举行追悼会。但在新宿的寺庙里，有一种明显的感觉，这次葬礼是不同的。有一种明显的感觉，这次葬礼是不同的。这一次，日本告别的不仅仅是这些个人的印章。那是《禀议书》。那个故事由丹尼尔·西莫制作，乔·罗森伯格编辑。当我们回来时，我们将与丹尼尔谈谈一个更具争议的传统，涉及
Hanco, which Japan is also struggling to bring to an end. After this. So I'm here with Daniel Simo. Hey, Dan. Hey, Roman. So I understand there's another element in the rise and your potential fall of honko that we didn't get a chance to touch on. Yeah, you know, something I've been interested in with this whole story has been the different ways that tradition can develop. I heard a lot about traditions in my reporting and they can often grow in quite an organic way, but sometimes it seems like they can just be fabricated. Right. Because in your story, it was clear that Hanco was a little bit of both because it had this really old aristocratic provenance, you know, stemming from China, but the current sort of use of Hanco
印章，日本也在努力终结它。广告之后。所以我在这里和丹尼尔·西莫在一起。嘿，丹。嘿，罗曼。所以我明白在印章的兴起和潜在的衰落中还有另一个我们没有机会触及的因素。是的，你知道，在这个整个故事中我一直感兴趣的事情是传统发展的不同方式。我在报道中听到了很多关于传统的事情，它们通常可以以相当有机的方式成长，但有时看起来它们可能只是被捏造出来的。对。因为在你的故事中，很明显印章有点两者兼有，因为它有这种非常古老的贵族血统，你知道，源自中国，但目前这种印章的使用
is really something that's like much more recent and much more, you know, design concocted for the present day. Yeah, yeah, exactly. And it turns out there's another supposedly ancient, quote, unquote, tradition, involving Hanco that's even more of a flat out, just invention. And it starts with this guy named Hikaru Sakamoto,
确实是更近期的东西，而且更多的是，你知道，为当下设计的。是的，是的，完全正确。事实证明，还有另一个所谓的古老的、引用引号的、涉及印章的传统，它更是一个彻头彻尾的虚构。它始于一个叫坂本光的人，
who was a traveling salesman from the prefecture of Yamanashi. Oh, I like a good traveling salesman story, okay. So what is it? Well, back in the 1960s, Sakamoto, the salesman, he was going around Yamanashi, selling jewelry to mostly wealthy customers. And this is when the economic boom that was happening in the 60s was it is just most boom-tastic. And people suddenly
他是一名来自山梨县的旅行推销员。哦，我喜欢好的旅行推销员故事，好的。那是什么？嗯，回到20世纪60年代，推销员坂本在山梨县四处走动，向大多数富有的客户推销珠宝。这是60年代经济繁荣时期，那是极其繁荣的。人们突然
had a lot more money to spend. So he went into their homes and he looked around and he noticed that they were making all these big expensive purchases. But when it came to Hancock, they were still using all these cheap wooden ones that were very common at the time. So, you know, like any good salesman, he saw an opportunity. So he saw all these cheap Hanco and he was like, oh, I can really upsell this market into something fancier. Yeah, so he decided to make and market a new type of luxury, Hanco, made out of a material that was mostly being used for things like pipes and cigarette filters at the time, and it was ivory.
有了更多的钱可以花。所以他走进他们的家，环顾四周，注意到他们正在进行所有这些昂贵的大额购买。但当谈到印章时，他们仍然在使用当时非常普遍的廉价木制印章。所以，你知道，像任何好的推销员一样，他看到了机会。所以他看到了所有这些廉价印章，他心想，哦，我可以真正把这个市场提升到更高级的东西。是的，所以他决定制造并推销一种新型的豪华印章，由当时主要用于烟斗和香烟过滤嘴等东西的材料制成，那就是象牙。
So, he started a company in 1967, and he began to market heavily to department stores and through mail order catalogs and door-to-door sales. And I should be clear, he wasn't the first one to make Hanco out of ivory, but he was definitely a visionary as far as the marketing goes. Okay, so what was his marketing like? Well, he put up ads on newspapers and magazines with pictures and drawings of elephants next to some really purple prose that portrayed elephants as these sacred animals. Take this newspaper ad, for example.
所以，他在1967年创办了一家公司，并开始大力向百货公司推销，并通过邮购目录和上门推销。我应该说明，他不是第一个用象牙制作印章的人，但他作为营销人员绝对是有远见的。好的，那他的营销方式是什么样的？嗯，他在报纸和杂志上刊登广告，上面有大象的图片和图画，旁边是一些非常华丽的文字，将大象描绘成这些神圣的动物。以这则报纸广告为例。
Okay, so this is a very busy ad with an elephant, you know, dead center in the middle. You know, when these little honko sats that are like, kind of beautifully displayed. Yeah. And if you look on the left, actually, there's a pack of two. And the one on the left is, it says it's a jitsu in, which is the real seal. And the one on the right is the ginkgo in, which is the bank seal. So you can get your set of ivory for all your needs that are right next to each other. So what is the ad copy? Because it's very dense with ad copy.
好的，所以这是一个非常繁忙的广告，中间有一头大象，你知道，正中央。你知道，当这些小印章套装被展示得非常漂亮时。是的。如果你看左边，实际上，有一套两个的。左边那个，它说是实印，也就是真正的印章。右边那个是银行印，也就是银行印章。所以你可以得到你的象牙套装，满足你所有的需求，它们就在彼此旁边。那广告文案是什么？因为它充满了广告文案。
So what is the ad copy, say? Well, basically, it's really talking up the elephant angle. And it's saying that because elephants live long lives in tight family groups, that people with ivory handcos will also enjoy long lives with good fortune. And this advertisement saidphant Library is the best Hancock material, combining fortune, elements, comfortable usage, and durability. That's Masayuki Sakamoto, no relation to traveling salesmen. Masayuki is a lawyer and environmental activist with the Japan Tiger and Elephant Fund. Here's him reading the rest of the ad.
那广告文案说了什么？嗯，基本上，它真的在吹捧大象的角度。它说因为大象在紧密的家庭群体中长寿，所以拥有象牙印章的人也会享受长寿和好运。这则广告说“象牙是最好的印章材料，结合了财富、优雅、舒适的使用和耐用性。”那是坂本正之，与旅行推销员坂本没有亲属关系。正之是一位律师和环境活动家，隶属于日本老虎和象基金会。这是他阅读广告的其余部分。
Elephant Library, since ancient times, is a protector against evil and symbol of prosperity, because elephants are not only the world's largest animal, but also the one making harmonious family. So it's Sakamoto here like the salesman Sakamoto. Is he tapping into some actual Japanese tradition here? Is he just sort of making this stuff up? You mean is it is ivory traditionally considered a lucky charm combining fortune and elegance and all that? Right, right, right. No, no, he just made that up.
“象牙，自古以来，就是辟邪和繁荣的象征，因为大象不仅是世界上最大的动物，也是和谐家庭的创造者。”所以坂本在这里，像推销员坂本一样。他是在利用某种实际的日本传统吗？还是他只是在编造这些东西？你的意思是象牙传统上被认为是结合了财富和优雅等等的幸运符吗？对，对，对。不，不，他只是编造的。
So if this is if he's sort of making this up whole cloth, I mean, how successful was this? It was hugely successful. I've heard the ads described as the Japanese equivalent of the Diamonds are Forever ad campaign. Oh, yeah. And soon other companies were copying these methods and Ivory Hancos just became this hot new luxury good and Just how it only took a generation really to convince people in the West that Diamond engagement rings were this age-old practice in Japan consumers really quickly brought into this idea that if you were going to get yourself
所以如果他是凭空捏造的，我的意思是，这有多成功？它非常成功。我听说这些广告被描述为日本版的“钻石恒久远”广告活动。哦，是的。很快其他公司也在复制这些方法，象牙印章就成了这种热门的新奢侈品。就像仅仅花了一代人的时间就说服西方人相信钻石订婚戒指是这种古老的习俗一样，在日本，消费者很快就接受了这种想法：如果你要给自己买
a good proper Hanco, it should be made out of ivory. So just like that, you had a new tradition being created. It was like a new tradition, even on kind of a new tradition, like all of it's pretty recent in the history of Japan. Oh, yeah, yeah, that's right. And then the demand for ivory just grew and grew throughout the 70s and 80s. And Masayuki Sakamoto says that Japan became the largest ivory importer in the world. And 80% of the low ivory was processed into Hancock.
一个好的、合适的印章，它应该由象牙制成。所以就这样，你创造了一个新的传统。这就像一个新传统，甚至是一种新传统，就像所有这些在历史中都是非常近期的。哦，是的，是的，没错。然后对象牙的需求在整个70年代和80年代不断增长。坂本正之说，日本成了世界上最大的象牙进口国。而80%的象牙被加工成了印章。
If you say 80% of that ivory, like how many Hanckos could that be? There is not enough information, but one document said in 1980 about 2 million HanKo was produced in one year. 2 million HanKo a year? That's, I had no idea that would be the amount. I mean, and then also, like, now that you mentioned this ivory part of it, that is a horrifying number. I mean, how many elephants had to die
如果你说80%的象牙，那会有多少印章？没有足够的信息，但一份文件说在1980年，一年内生产了大约200万枚印章。一年200万枚印章？那是，我不知道会有这么多。我的意思是，而且，现在你提到了象牙的部分，那是一个令人恐惧的数字。我的意思是，有多少大象必须死
to feed this fancy hanko habit? Well, there was a report released in 2018 by the Environmental Investigation Agency, which estimated that since 1970, more than 260,000 elephants had been killed to supply Japan with ivory. And again, most of that ivory was just going into making Hanco. And in the 1980s, elephant numbers dropped so much that there was a big international push to ban the trade of ivory, which eventually led to the ratification in 1989 of the ivory band through something
才能满足这种高级印章的习惯？嗯，环境调查署在2018年发布了一份报告，估计自1970年以来，为了向日本供应象牙，已经有超过26万头大象被杀。同样，大部分象牙只是用于制作印章。在20世纪80年代，大象数量下降得如此之多，以至于国际上掀起了一股禁止象牙贸易的大浪潮，这最终导致了1989年通过某种方式批准了象牙禁令
called Cytis, which was the convention on international trade in endangered species. But the thing is, even though there was a band, it didn't necessarily have the full desired effect. Because remember the ad that I showed you earlier? That was from 1998. Whoa. So you said that the band was in 89. So this is nine years later. So that they're advertising that they have fantastic ivory honko in an ad nine years after the band. Yeah. Yeah. That's right. Wow. And the reason for that is simple in reality
称为《濒危野生动植物种国际贸易公约》（CITES）。但问题是，尽管有禁令，它并不一定产生了预期的全部效果。因为还记得我之前给你看的那个广告吗？那是1998年的。哇。所以你说禁令是在89年。所以这是九年后。所以他们在禁令九年后还在广告中宣传他们有极好的象牙印章。是的。是的。没错。哇。而原因很简单，实际上
Just import is prohibited, but sharing and buying is free in Japan So it's still legal in Japan. Oh, so you can't import any more ivory into the country But all the ivory that was there in Japan before the ban That can be turned into Wonkoo and Perkjust and Sold until it runs out. Yeah, exactly. And on top of that, Japan lobbied successfully
在日本，仅仅是禁止进口，但买卖和分享是自由的，所以它在日本仍然是合法的。哦，所以你不能再向国内进口象牙了，但禁令之前在日本国内的所有象牙，都可以被制成判子（印章）和各种制品，直到卖完为止。是的，完全正确。而且最重要的是，日本成功游说
for there to be two final shipments of ivory after the ban. So there was one in 1997 and this one, like China also got in on this one in 2008. And that ivory is still being used. Wow. So are they almost out of ivory? I mean, is this the end of ivory in Japan? Like if I walked into a honko shop today, could I buy an ivory honko?
在禁令之后又进行了两次象牙进口。一次是在1997年，另一次是2008年，中国也参与了那次。那些象牙至今仍在使用。哇。所以他们的象牙快用完了吗？我的意思是，这是日本象牙贸易的终点吗？如果我今天走进一家判子店，我能买到象牙判子吗？
For the most part, yeah. It's not advertised as heavily as it used to be. And some shops might just refuse to sell it, but it is available. And if you really want to, you can still get your ivory seal. Even now, anyone can buy ivory very openly. The regulation is just when you buy a whole task, you have to get a registration in advance. But if registered library tasks, you can buy freely.
大部分情况下，可以。它不像以前那样被大肆宣传了。有些店可能会拒绝出售，但它确实有售。如果你真的想要，你仍然可以买到象牙印章。即使是现在，任何人都可以非常公开地购买象牙。规定只是当你购买整根象牙时，需要提前登记。但如果是已登记的象牙，你可以自由购买。
Oh my god, you buy an library task. This doesn't seem like a ban at all. Yeah, it's kind of crazy. And one concern with all this is that because there is still a legal domestic trade for ivory, some people worry that whenever you have a legal trade in something that this continues to feed the illegal trade going into the country. Totally. I mean, because people can still hypothetically smuggle ivory into the country illegally. And it's like laundered by the time it enters into retail. You could just say, oh, this came from before 2008 or the last shipment. I mean, is there a notion from your experts that the legal part of this trade is feeding the illegal import of ivory still?
天哪，你竟然能买到象牙。这看起来根本不像禁令。是的，这有点疯狂。对此的一个担忧是，由于日本国内仍然存在合法的象牙贸易，有些人担心，只要某种东西存在合法贸易，就会持续助长非法进口。完全同意。因为人们在理论上仍然可以非法走私象牙进入国内。当它进入零售环节时，就已经被“洗白”了。你可以说，哦，这是2008年之前或最后一次进口的存货。那么，专家们是否认为这种合法的贸易部分仍在助长象牙的非法进口？
Yeah, there is. And especially because the regulations are so lax in a way, it's mostly, you know, the only thing you have to register is that whole tusk. But as soon as you cut a tusk and two, you don't have to register it. Wow. I should say that there has been more and more pressure building in the last decade or so.
是的，确实如此。特别是由于监管在某种程度上非常宽松，你唯一需要登记的就是那整根象牙。但一旦你把象牙切成两半，就不需要登记了。哇。我应该说，在过去十年左右的时间里，压力越来越大了。
And two of the main online retailers now here in Japan, Yahoo and Rakuten, have actually banned sales of ivory on their platforms. And a lot of socially conscious Japanese consumers actually might feel a little conflicted about buying ivory now. And, you know, actually the Tokyo Olympics, which are starting very soon, were supposed to be a big turning point for this. Because anti-Avery campaigners were hoping that holding a large international event in Japan would help to shine a light on the problem.
现在日本的两大在线零售商，雅虎和乐天，实际上已经禁止在其平台上销售象牙。许多有社会意识的日本消费者现在在购买象牙时可能会感到有些矛盾。而且，你知道，即将开始的东京奥运会本应是解决这个问题的一个重大转折点。因为反象牙运动人士希望，在日本举办一场大型国际赛事将有助于让人们关注这个问题。
People coming from all over the world, many of whom might want to buy a traditional souvenir while they're in town. Like they can pick up their own honko. And yeah, exactly. So they were hoping that that kind of scrutiny might force the Japanese government to once and for all ban the sale of ivory. So they were imagining the scenario of the Olympics
来自世界各地的人们，其中许多人可能想在城里买点传统纪念品。比如他们可以买自己的判子。是的，完全正确。所以他们希望这种关注度能迫使日本政府彻底禁止象牙销售。所以他们设想了奥运会的场景，
and all these international tourists coming in and they walk into a retail shop to buy honko and the retail shop is covered in ivory, and they would be disgusted, and this would cause enough pressure on the Japanese government to do something about the retail ivory trade. Yeah, that was the basic plan. But as you probably know, because of COVID, there are no spectators allowed at the games now. And since we're in a state of emergency here anyway, there probably won't be a lot of souvenir shopping. So this opportunity to really shine that international
所有这些国际游客进来，走进一家零售店想买判子，结果发现店里到处都是象牙，他们会感到厌恶，这会给日本政府施加足够的压力，从而对零售象牙贸易采取行动。是的，这就是基本计划。但正如你可能知道的，因为新冠疫情，现在比赛不允许观众入场。而且既然我们处于紧急状态，可能也不会有太多的纪念品购物。所以这个真正让国际社会关注
light on the ivory problem in Japan isn't really going to happen. And Masayuki Sakamoto says that even as most of the rest of the world has already banned ivory sales of all kinds, the Japanese government continues to support them. Their ivory policy is just to protect ivory industry, regardless of the change of the situation of African elephants and the change of the international countries. Only Japan has not changed. That is so frustrating. I mean, it makes me mad. Yeah. So, you know, just like the Hanco itself, the use of ivory in Japan is a tradition that was easy to invent, but it's proving really hard to kill.
日本象牙问题的机会实际上不会发生了。坂本正幸说，即使世界其他大部分地区已经禁止了各种形式的象牙销售，日本政府仍继续支持它们。他们的象牙政策只是为了保护象牙产业，而不顾非洲象的处境变化和国际社会的变化。只有日本没有改变。这太令人沮丧了。我的意思是，这让我很生气。是的。所以，就像判子本身一样，象牙在日本的使用是一种很容易发明但却很难根除的传统。
Well, thank you so much for adding this part of this, because I'm sure people who know Hunk are really well, we're kind of thinking it, so I'm glad that we sort of like addressed it. This is something that hopefully people will pay attention to in the future. I really appreciate it. It was super fascinating. I love the whole story. Thank you, Arman.
好吧，非常感谢你补充了这一部分，因为我相信那些非常了解判子的人肯定也在思考这个问题，所以我很高兴我们解决了它。希望人们在未来能关注这一点。我真的很感激。这非常引人入胜。我喜欢整个故事。谢谢你，Arman。
99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Daniel Simo, edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed in tech production by Jim Briggs, music by our director of sound Sean Riel. Delaney Hall is the executive producer, Kurt Colstad is the digital director, the rest of the team includes Vivian Le, Emmett Fitzgerald, Chris Baroube, Christopher Johnson, Lashima Dawn, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher & Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook, you can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 9-9-PI-O-RK. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher
《99% Invisible》本周由Daniel Simo制作，Joe Rosenberg编辑，Jim Briggs进行技术制作和混音，音乐由我们的声音总监Sean Riel负责。Delaney Hall是执行制片人，Kurt Colstad是数字总监，团队其他成员包括Vivian Le、Emmett Fitzgerald、Chris Baroube、Christopher Johnson、Lashima Dawn、Sophia Klatsker以及我Roman Mars。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Pandora大楼，向北六个街区。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论，你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars和节目@99PIorg。我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。你可以找到其他Stitcher节目的链接，
shows I love as well as every past episode of 9-9-PI at 9-9-PI dot org. Memo to myself. Schedule meeting to get official stitcher audio logo. Stitcher, Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk Tuk T Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及《99% Invisible》的每一集往期节目，网址是99pi.org。备忘录：安排会议获取官方Stitcher音频标志。Stitcher，谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。